so we're clear for the audience what is
freeman dyson's position on it and
stephen hawkings and then
why do you disagree like where is the
disagreement between you and so he says
i i think now where did this come from
he hasn't written
extensively on this i think in the new
york review books
when okay i think when he was reviewing
brian greene's
uh book um he as in
hawking or or dyson the freeman dyson
yeah freeman
um he said look girls incompleteness
theorem shows
that there are an exhaustible number of
true propositions in mathematics that
can't be
true and because of the that we can't
show is true i'm sorry
you're and um because of this
since um physics uses
mathematics it follows that there are an
inexhaustible number of
physical propositions which can't be
proved true
and i say you're saying that that's a
leap
i say that to lee i say that's a
non-sequitur actually
so um yeah okay let's get to tarsky we
would spend the entire
hour talking about this stuff it's
extremely rich and extremely
complicated and i think for me always
it's
let's first look at the incompleteness
theorem see what they're proving
how they prove it um
you know the fact that they're proving
something about formal systems
of arithmetic we can't prove you know
and so
in this theory of everything we will not
be able to prove
um uh complicated views uh
complicated truths about the integers
but we don't need to do that anyway in
doing physics that's not the kind of
math we use
you